let's debate whether children kept in
cages deserve things like beds and
toothbrushes and soap this is how far
the Overton Window has moved on the
issue of child detentions and
separations and incarceration or to put
it another way this is how much creeping
normality there has been on the issue of
caging children so let me explain those
two terms because these are important
when I talk about the Overton Window and
I say the Overton Window has shifted on
this issue the Overton Window is the
range of what's acceptable for debate in
the public discourse okay so for example
in the area of nuclear weapons the
Overton Window more or less ranges from
everybody who wants nukes should have
nukes or everyone should have nukes sort
of on one side - no one should have
nukes and there should or shouldn't be
international agreements limiting who
has nukes and there should or shouldn't
be punishments like international
sanctions for people for countries that
violate agreements on nukes okay that's
sort of all within the Overton Window on
nuclear weapons outside of the Overton
Window right now would be the position
that if a country develops nuclear
weapons when they shouldn't we capture
torture and kill the children of whoever
is president or prime minister at the
time
all right that's a cartoonish example
but that is a piece a position on
nuclear weapons that is outside of the
Overton Window right now it's not when
you hear that you don't consider that to
be part of what is the acceptable a
spectrum of debate or position on
nuclear weapons
that's Overton Window creeping normality
is another term where you can't jump to
where we are today it has to creep in
slowly normalizing so as an example if
20 years ago someone had said let's
radicalize half the country on
immigration so that they think brown
people from Latin America are the enemy
who are taped taking our jobs and raping
us and then let's start putting children
who come here with undocumented parents
in cages and we only have to debate do
those kids deserve soap and beds and
toothbrushes that would be too much but
that creeps in over 20 years and here we
are debating do children in the custody
of Border Patrol deserve and are they
entitled to base
hygiene and bedding items and in fact we
have a trump Justice Department lawyer
who recently insisted in court that safe
and sanitary conditions is a vague term
and it may not include something as
basic as a bar of soap or a toothbrush
or a blanket for the fully lit cold
rooms in which these children are forced
to sleep or at least try to sleep is
being able to sleep at all part of safe
and sanitary well Trump's Justice
Department lawyer Sarah Fabian argued
it's not totally clear that it is I'm
gonna play some of this video for you of
the lawyer arguing with the judges I'm
going to show you several minutes of it
so that you can see this wasn't a minor
part of this hearing this is an
important and key part of the hearing
they are debating how should these
children who have committed no crime who
were just brought here by their parents
and have been taken into custody by
Border Patrol how should they be treated
and do they even deserve something like
soap take a listen to what took place in
a court just a few days ago but you're
really gonna stand up and tell us that
that being able to sleep isn't a
question of safe and sanitary conditions
Your Honor I think what I'd like to what
I'd like to stand up and say is the
focus is to focus the court on what what
the question is any number of things
might fall under those categories and I
think sleep surely does right you can't
be safe and and and sanitary are safe as
a human being if you can't sleep well
and you said in your brief so doesn't
say anything about sleeping so therefore
there's nothing in here about that being
able to sleep I think the concern there
is Your Honor the court finding that
sleep for example falls under is
relevant to a finding of no safe and
sanitary conditions it is one thing but
the ultimate conclusion is
safe and sanitary is a singular category
in the agreement and it was it was one
has to assume left that way and not
enumerated by the parties because either
the parties couldn't reach agreement on
how to enumerate that or that it was
left to the agencies to determine to
determine or it was relatively obvious
and its least obvious enough so that if
you're putting two people's into a
crowded room to sleep on a concrete
floor with an aluminum foil blanket on
top of them that doesn't comply with the
agreement I mean it may be that they
don't get super thread-count Egyptian
linens I get that but the testimony that
the district judge believed was it's
really cold fact it gets colder when we
complain about is being cold we're
sports to sleep crowded with the lights
on all night long and all you do put us
on is the concrete floor with an
aluminum blanket I mean I understand
it's some outer boundary there may be
some definitional difficulty but no one
would argue that this is secure and
sanity or say a safe and sanitary portal
at least I don't think you're arguing
that are you Your Honor I think what I'm
arguing is that the the the way that the
district court reached the conclusion
was to say these these specific items
and I think I will acknowledge I think
sleep is the more difficult end of what
I'm arguing when you started numerating
for example specific hygiene items and
the way that was done is that the the
court in sort of enumerated these and
say these fall under the rubric these
following the category of what could be
required and it wasn't proof to him soap
it was sold wasn't you know
high-class milled so it was so and that
sound stole that's part of a safe and
sanitary it's within everybody's common
understanding that you know if you don't
have a toothbrush if you don't have soap
if you don't have a blanket it's not
safe and sanitary well wouldn't
everybody agree to that do you agree to
that well I think it's I think desert
there's fair reason to find that those
things may be part of seeing maybe a
heart apart what do you say maybe this
is what it sounds like okay we are
debating does a six-year-old separated
from his or her parents through no fault
of their own and put in a crowded crappy
facility do they get soap do they get a
blanket despite having the lights on all
night and being super cold and being in
close proximity with other people making
basic hygiene even more important to
prevent the spread of disease and germs
this is the debate that we are having
not only in our legal system but also in
the political world because there are
trumpets who are on apparently the side
of the lawyer that it's not clear that
these children who have done nothing
wrong deserve these things now I know
lots of lawyers and I understand you
argue for your client I've met George
Zimmerman's lawyer and and spent some
time with him and I've gotten an
interesting perspective of his view on
this issue of he doesn't have to like
George Zimmerman to believe that George
Zimmerman deserves a defense but then it
starts to get more complicated when you
get into some of these specific
situations you argue for your client not
necessarily for what you believe but how
does this woman sleep at night
everything that is taking place here is
completely backwards and I hate to even
go to a financial argument because for
me the moral argument and the legal
argument are so obvious here but to make
a financial argument isn't it much
cheaper to spend some money on soap and
blankets and toothbrushes and prevent
the types of illness and disease that
would spread if kids can't sleep and
can't clean themselves isn't that much
cheaper than having to treat the
diseases and conditions that would arise
from no
hygiene in such crowded and concentrated
situations although maybe the whole
point is they don't really have a plan
of treating those conditions anyway and
secondly if you look at what it costs to
keep these kids detained and estimates
ranged from $300 a day up to 750 dollars
a day or more how are we not able to
just obviously afford and have the soap
and betting on hand which is why this
gets to I don't actually think that the
financial issue is the issue this gets
back to that strict father morality I've
spoken about before which is it doesn't
matter if we can afford it doesn't
matter if even legally there's a case to
be made that these basic hygiene
products should be provided to these
kids there is a contingent in this
country that on a moral level believes
that children whose parents came to the
United States illegally or came to the
border legally seeking asylum that the
children as a result don't deserve soap
when the United States decides to
enforce and carry out a policy of
putting these kids in what are
effectively cages and there are other
terms we could even use when you talk
about the crowded conditions it is
absolutely stunning that this is a
debate that we're having but this is how
the discourse has gone in the United
States over the last 20 years the
Overton Window has shifted there has
been creeping normalization of this
stuff and this is where we are in 2019
and it doesn't bode well for us as a
society doesn't bode well for us as an
economy doesn't bode well for us as a
country it's sad and depressing but this
is the reality today one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap him in this really
funny and intelligent two-player card
game and you can get it for 10% off when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach
and use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word
impeach the card slap game is perfect
for having friends over or hanging out
with family members who have a sense of
humor about Trump we've been playing it
at my place it currently has a 5 out of
5 star rating on Amazon I really don't
think you'll be able to find a game that
does a better job of satirizing today's
political climate in such an intelligent
way I've had a ton of fun
it and I think you will too you can tell
a ton of time and careful thought went
into the game design and the cartoon
artwork and the humor it never gets old
because you're always discovering new
jokes and political commentary within
the game we were talking to the creators
of the game and they said one of their
goals was that players might even learn
something new as they play I think it
would make a perfect gift for anyone
really of any political orientation just
because of how clever it is or you can
get it for yourself and have a really
fun and witty game to play when people
come over get impeach the cards slap
game by going to david pakman.com slash
impeach and get 10% off when you use the
coupon code pakman show at checkout
that's all one word Pakman show